بعد ذلك تبدا رحله الصمغ التجاريه بدءا
بشراء المحصول بكميات كبيره وهو في حاله
رطبه ثم تجفيفه قبل معالجته من الشوائب ثم
تعبئته لتصدير المباشر او التصنيع المصنف
[موسيقى]
هل نحن نشتري عبر الوكاله في الاسواق
المختلفه في داخل سوق محصلات البيض بياتي
الكميه لداخل لما خازن بتاعتنا اللي هو
منتج بيكون في بدايه في رطوبه بيعرض
للتجفيف بعد ذلك
اجراءات النظافه الاوليه ثم النظافه
النهائيه
[موسيقى]
الطلب بيختلف من زبون زبون في عندنا نحن
بنشتغل خمسه مختلفه يعني من الكم الواحده
مثلا
[موسيقى]
ابوايم فايف حسب حسب الحجم الطرف يعني
صناعه المياه الغازيه العصائر
الادويه مستحضرات التجميل
وربما لا يعرف كثيرون ان لحاء اشجار الطلح
المنتجه لاحد انواع الصمغ العربي تدخل في
صناعه منتجات ذات استخدامات يوميه كاعواد
الكبريت وبعض انواع البخور وكذلك الالعاب
الناريه
وعلى الرغم من ان رواد هذه الصناعه ماضون
في تذليل الصعاب والتغلب على كل المعيقات
والتحديات الا ان بعضها ما يزال ماثلا
كتهريب المنتج عبر الحدود الممتده الامر
الذي يدفع ثمنه من اختار الاستثمار بالطرق
المشروعه فضلا عن بعض التحديات اللوجستيه
التي تتسبب فيها عوامل مرتبطه بتطورات
الوضع الاقتصادي والسياسي العام في البلاد
اكبر المشاكل اللي بتلاقينا هي المشاكل
بتاعه
الديمومه والاستمراريه والاستدامه حقت
الانتاج
واسباب كثيره منها القطع الجائر للشجار او
القطعه المقصود على الاشجار
والهجره الحاصله في في مناطق الانتاج من
قبل
المزارعين السبب الاساسي في قطع الاشجار
هو يعني او السببين الاساسيات اللي بيعدوا
الى قطع الاشجار هم الاسعار المدنيه
عالميا في بعض المواسم بتضغط
التجاره والمصدرين ومن ثم
المنتجين في الازهار مما تجبرون لانه
يمشوا لبدائل اخرى يعني غير السماء العربي